Clarence Thomas: You are men and women of
Hillsdale, steeped in the best traditions
and principles of our great nation.
If you don’t lead by example, who will?
Nick: Today, the Liberal Arts are under attack,
and Hillsdale College is the best defense
it could hope for.
We’ve read the old books and engaged in
a dialogue which recognizes that the answers are
not easily found.
We went scuba diving at Sombrero Reef.
It was amazing.
It was cool to be on my own and just explore,
see all the fish and all the colors, explore
the caves that the eels were hiding in.
It was just a great experience
The trip was a really cool combination of
the biblical sites and being exposed to the
geo-political situation in Israel.
They’re not going to get him.
To the five, he’s going to the end zone!
Touchdown!
Bart Spieth: Our shotgun team is really great.
They are very competitive.
They've won four of the last five years in Division III national championships.
Larry Arnn: The College is old. It’s a wonderful
thing about it.
It was founded by heroes and wise people.
They founded it just like the United States
was founded: according to principles they
claim to be eternal.
Scott Pruitt: The importance of who replaces
Justice Scalia, and the principles that they
embody will make a huge difference in the
liberties and freedoms that we have in the
future.
David Clarke: There is no higher honor than
to wear the uniform of the United States
and go and defend freedom.
There is no higher honor.
Jeff Sessions: I love this Constitution.
I love the rule of law.
It’s a rare, special, unbelievably valuable
and unique tradition that we inherited.
Clarence Thomas: This is Hillsdale College,
and you are special—that shining City on
a Hill.
May God bless each of you now and throughout your
lives, and may God bless America.